what's going on guys this is rob and we
are covering the new venom this is the
beginning of the run by al ewing now
here's the thing i'm going to tell you
this ahead of time after reading through
this story if you did not like al
ewing's immortal hulk you will not like
this these two things basically are
identical in terms of how he writes them
and how they're drawn having said that
immortal hulk had its low periods it had
its slow moments but overall it was
great
you know kind of sitting back and and
looking at it like it was just one of
the most unique incredible hulk stories
that had ever been written seemingly
since the days of bill mantle and peter
david right really bill matlow more than
peter david but this one feels like it's
going to be a lot the same way so it's
going to be a very cerebral story and a
lot of new concepts and some other
concepts that al ewing is actually built
on or created they're going to be thrown
in here specifically some of the stuff
that we saw from the ultimates if that
gives you any indication initially this
picks up with what really looks like
pandemonium right like a hotel room
being trashed and basically all these
soldiers and then i'm just kind of
jumping into the fray and seemingly
attacking all these people at that
moment you switch over to about 12 hours
before all this kicked off and what you
end up doing is joining with eddie brock
now a little bit of a refresher here for
those of you guys who don't really
recall where we left off with eddie
brock that you basically had null the
symbiote god essentially the being who
created the symbiotes in the first place
he had basically returned he conscripted
the symbiotes he actually took over
celestials using the living darkness and
then in turn started quite literally
cutting a swath through the universe i
know it's been a long time since we used
that phrase cutting a swath but he
basically led this huge crusade this
rampage across the universe conquered
countless worlds all that kind of stuff
until eventually he arrived on earth and
then eventually eddie brock got his
hands on what was basically the enigma
force he became captain universe and
then defeated null following that he
took his place and so where eddie brock
is not really a villain instead he's
basically a hero now what's happening is
that he is essentially controlling the
symbiotes from a remote location right
so the symbiotes exist out there in
space through all corners of the
universe and the idea is that in the
early days the symbiotes were after
they're really after the defeat of null
and them kind of becoming their own
thing until null rose again they were
space knights right so the role that
symbiotes would play is they would bond
themselves to individuals and then they
would become protectors not unlike the
green lantern corps from dc comics
albeit the mode and the method by which
they operated was different it was more
or less the same concept in terms of how
far-reaching they were and so that's
basically where they returned to right
that with eddie brock leading the charge
kind of controlling them being able to
jump from one mind to the next that he's
basically leading this giant army of
symbiotes across the universe basically
trying to save lives where he can and
what he ends up doing is coming across a
really a ship that's on a mission of
mercy right it's really more at least as
he describes it as a ship that's
basically a relief freighter right so
it's got medicine it's got food
different things like that and this is
just kind of the aftermath of the king
and black because so many worlds were
conquered because so many worlds were
pillaged or even destroyed that there's
basically a lot of relief efforts
underway across the universe where
people are sending supplies to whoever
they can in order to try to get the
universe back up to where it was
supposed to be it's not one of these
things that you see very often these
days you saw it all the time during the
days of like dan admit when he was doing
the whole uh like like cosmic opera
right so like everything from
annihilation going forward which is
still probably the best era of space
faring stories in the history of marvel
comics we need to cover the entirety of
dan abner's run one day like we need to
do that i mean we already covered it in
bits and pieces right like thanos
imperative different things like that
but we should cover it all one of the
things to keep in mind here is that
these four symbiotes are by and large
kind of autonomous the reason why you
see the at least one of the symbiotes
that looks more like venom than the
others it's really more of just an
artistic depiction to show us which one
eddie brock is controlling and that's
the way it works his consciousness jumps
from one to the next so essentially he
can be in a room with one symbiote and
then jump to the to the mind of another
symbiote take that one over and then
just kind of operate there accordingly
so it's a pretty ingenious way in terms
of how he functions but as they make
their way through the ships they
basically end up finding that of course
space pirates have taken this thing now
that's just part and parcel to what's
going on out there right now right like
anytime you have a situation where there
is a dire need for a particular product
you're going to have people who are
basically going to hijack that process
and essentially become pirates right
like selling them off for for super high
amounts of money here on earth in the
modern era we call them scalpers right
but they're still basically the same
thing pirates more or less and so as a
result of this it's one of these things
where like these symbiotes kind of go
through and basically face off against
these guys but one of the other things
to understand is that even though they
are pirates and they are basically bad
guys that they still don't trust the the
concept of symbiotes now this is
something alewing gives us is not just a
reflection of these pirates but
basically most life across the universe
but because null had conquered so many
different worlds or destroyed so many
different worlds it has forever changed
the way that people see symbiotes in
time that will change but at the moment
they distrust them greatly and so it's
one of those things where it's like
attack on sight as soon as you see him
it's pretty wild in in terms of how this
works but switching back over to dylan
right the son of eddie brock from the
whole king and black event and all that
kind of stuff one of the things you see
here is that where he had basically been
left on earth by by eddie and eddie has
spent more and more time away from earth
trying to be a protector across the
universe using his venom army basically
a symbiote army that in a lot of ways
it's left dylan to his own devices and
one of the things to know is that when
you're younger when you're somebody like
dylan who i wouldn't say has been been
raised in a life of conflict but who was
physically abused by his grandfather one
of the things he's learned is that
violence solves everything now in all
honesty let's be truthful here violence
is not always the answer that's true but
as you guys have heard me say countless
times it is a answer and it's usually a
very effective one and so dylan is
really kind of taking that approach the
problem is he's going too extreme with
it and so basically getting into fights
different things like that when he's
called into the principal's office the
response is if we can't get a hold of
your dad we're gonna have to inform the
board of education and ultimately we're
gonna have to kick you out of the school
right we'll have to expel you for what
you're doing and so one of the big
things that dylan is contending with is
not only the struggle of just coming of
age right i mean a lot of you guys who
are young who have been through this
process i remember this process you guys
understand it's a lot of hormones a lot
of confusion you don't know who you are
where you're going what you're about how
you feel about things seemingly changes
all the time you almost feel like you're
not in control of your own life and so
we're dylan is trying to to deal with
that whole process just the the price
you pay for growing up he also has to
deal with abandonment issues the feeling
that like his father abandoned him in
order to be a protector of the universe
that dylan's just not more important
than that and where dylan does try to
reconcile this with well i mean it is
the universe and he has a protector at
the end of the day he still feels like
his father abandoned him and so as a
result of that this is a lot of anger
issue that's coming out right a lot of a
lot of anger problems that are
manifesting here and in his frustration
with how he feels like he's been
abandoned by his father and so where
eddie brock is basically able to tangle
up you know all these these you know
pirates or whatever and deal with them
one of the symbiotes that he had
nicknamed ringo he basically sent in to
the cargo hold to check out all the
people who were there and as soon as he
gets there you end up finding out that
this symbiote basically killed everybody
in there but it wasn't just the symbiote
going awry that's the first thing i want
to establish here and the way that that
alley-wing does this is fantastic it's
the same thing you did in immortal hulk
right like he teased this concept and
was like this is going to be the main
main idea going throughout the entirety
of this run however long this run may
last and so where this happens eddie
brock steps in here realizes all these
innocent people have basically been
slaughtered the symbiote starts speaking
to him right and it says don't sit too
comfortably on your throne king in black
soon it will be empty this is not a
threat not a warning simply a statement
of fact you will not know the day nor
the hour you won't see it coming eddie
so say your goodbyes now talk to the
people you love your son your other tell
them to run tell them to hide it won't
make any difference and it's one of the
things that eddie brock kind of
communicates here right that he says
that the way this thing talks it almost
kind of comes across as though it's
basically already one and words saying
things like this is a message from the
future that kind of seems to be
solidified right that like basically
it's already won that eddie brock has
already lost and there's no way for him
to stop himself from losing but as you
guys know eddie brock was never one to
just roll over right he was never one to
just say okay well i mean i guess i lost
might as well just gonna give up you
know call it a day he's the one to
always keep fighting right to always
keep going as best he can to come out on
top and so what he ends up doing is
basically racing back to dylan as fast
as he can wakes him up out of a dead
sleep and says like you have to get
dressed and he asked him he's like
where's the symbiote right where's venom
and the response that he that dylan
gives him is well he just kind of goes
out and does his own thing i mean i
guess he's trying to figure out you know
his place in all this but like he does
his own thing and there really haven't
been any venom sightings he hasn't like
consumed anybody so i figured everything
was okay and so the response of eddie is
okay fine whatever uh as always the rule
is do not bond to the venom symbiote
right you can use it if you need to but
do not actually bond to it right do not
stick with it for any real measure of
time but get dressed get your stuff
packed we got to get out of here as fast
as we possibly can now here's the crazy
thing about this is that while all
that's happening his phone starts
buzzing and when he goes to answer it
it's his dad it's eddie brock who tells
him
hey son you're in serious danger here
right you are in incredible danger uh
it's in there with you now we're not
really given a definitive what it is but
we can largely assume it's whatever it
was that took control of that ringo
symbiote that was talking to eddie and
killed all those innocent people how far
reaching this goes we don't know we
don't really know what we're dealing
with here we simply know we're just
dealing with some kind of a force that
claims to be able to send messages from
the future but whatever it is it's able
to seemingly take on the forms of other
people and so this really seems like the
legitimate eddie brock who's talking to
his son where dylan says like how do i
know it's you right like how do i know
it's actually you and not somebody else
pretending to be you and he's like
because i'm your father dylan right and
he's like how do i know i can trust you
he says you don't you just have to trust
yourself answer the question is it me or
is it is it somebody else's talking to
you on the phone right now and
ultimately dylan ends up siding with the
version of his dad on the phone and then
basically leaves that you know that
other person behind which more or less
seems to kind of be a symbiote now one
of the things that happens is that as
eddie talks to his son it's a bit of a
reminder that it really is eddie brock
right he says i wish i could talk you
through it son but i don't have a lot of
time i need you to go to the old motel
by the exit to central you remember the
one with the diner with the burnt
pancakes that you always hated he says
go now i'm in room 112. i'll see you
there and he says remember dylan don't
draw any attention to yourself don't get
into any trouble and i know you said you
haven't seen venom but in case you do
remember don't bond with the symbiote
and one of the things that's really kind
of cool here is that you've got eddie in
this hotel room just kind of mulling
over everything that's going on and one
of the things that he says here is that
like at the end of the day he wishes he
could have told his son that he loved
him right he wished he could have said
dylan i love you but he said there was
so much other stuff to say there were so
many other warnings that needed to be
given to him and so he's like now i'm
second guessing every single decision
that i made maybe i could just leave him
a message right maybe i could just leave
a message here in this location and like
that would be it but at the end of the
day eddie starts thinking and he comes
to this realization if this thing
whatever it was was able to communicate
to me through essentially hijacking one
of my symbiotes and i wasn't able to
retake control and it told me it was
sending a message from the future then
we're talking about time and so then his
mind starts wandering even further and
he says okay like according to einstein
time and space are are the same you
can't separate one you can't travel
through time but not travel through
space at the same time it doesn't work
that way they go hand in hand and so his
idea is if i can send my consciousness
into a symbiote on the other side of the
universe then what if i can send my mind
into a symbiote at any point in the
timeline right like into the future in
the past now this is huge it doesn't
seem like it's huge but this is huge
because this potentially introduces the
idea that eddie brock can manipulate
time that's big now this is not
something where it's like eddie brock
can manipulate tom because he's got
powers it's really just the fact that
the symbiotes serve as a bridge by way
he can do that right where it was it's
one of the things that really seemed to
give null the upper hand in a multitude
of circumstances because he had
basically already saw how he'd won right
so how that reconciles with the ending
of king and black and all that kind of
stuff i don't really know right i'm just
kind of spitballing here just throwing
out ideas but eddie brock does that
right he sends his mind seemingly into
the future and he gets a few small
glimpses right the boy is our only
priority which is what a pilot in a
helicopter says you end up seeing what
looks like a giant symbiotic monster
that says bedlam is my name right king
the conqueror appears which makes
perfect sense if it is some kind of
event that takes place in the future but
he says i tell you this as your oldest
friend edward you cannot win now we
don't know if kane the conqueror is
saying that as he observes eddie brock
moving through time and basically gives
him a warning or if that's like a
conversation that takes place in the
future seemingly it will be that's kind
of how aluing handled things when it
came to the immortal hulk all the stuff
you see here are things that we're gonna
see later on down the road right whether
it's at the end of this comic or things
in like 20 issues right whatever it
happens to be it'll be things that you
end up seeing the problem with this is
that because of the whole experience
seemingly this whole ordeal and the fact
that one taking over the mind of a
symbiote and controlling symbiotes
across the universe is already mentally
taxing this is doubly so so he actually
ends up passing out now of course he
wakes up dylan's basically calling him
and then ultimately eddie's response is
no like i shouldn't have stayed here i
shouldn't have told him to come and meet
me here they could follow him here they
could arrive here his hope was to bail
out and leave a message for his son so
his son would know what to do next but
the fact that he basically passed out
time has passed dylan is now here and so
he's like okay fine then we'll do what
we have to do right we'll basically work
together as best we can and i'll have to
keep him safe every step of the way the
problem is that in the middle of all
this suddenly like these just
military-grade helicopters come out of
nowhere fire rockets in the hotel and
basically end up killing eddie brock and
eddie brock is totally destroyed here
now this is one of the coolest things
from this comment because you know what
this reminds me of it reminds me of jeff
lemire and andreas sorrentino's old man
logan you guys remember that that part
that segment during border town when
like old man logan started flipping out
he went into his berserker mode and he
was just like let myself become wrath
let myself become death right just like
he just totally like just immerses
himself right just lets himself fall
into his berserker rage this is like
that that seemingly the other basically
arrives on the scene right the the venom
symbiote saves dylan bonds itself to
dylan even though dylan knows that's not
supposed to happen and he kills everyone
right like everyone i mean this kind of
wraps back around to the very beginning
but basically he kills everybody here
all these soldiers he just kills them
all and it's not like there's five or
six soldiers or a few soldiers in
helicopters there's dozens of them and
all of them get killed by dylan as venom
right he just goes on this rampage just
losing himself in this whole thing and
that's one of the things that's kind of
commented here is this is how it all
begins so seemingly the indication is
it's dylan dylan becomes evil corrupted
so really kind of seemingly tying back
into the work of what donnie cates did
when he basically gave us this kind of
futuristic story where dylan ended up
becoming what was basically an agent of
null and then in turn was controlling
all the symbiotes across the world and
actually killed the world superheroes
and most of the population and turned
them into symbiotes and then in turn
they all worked for him then it looks
like it might be some form of a game of
global domination now while that may
seem pretty basic and kind of lame do
not take that as an absolute truth you
talk to anybody who read immortal hulk
it seemed pretty basic to begin with by
the time you got midway through it was
phenomenal it was just this ridiculously
great story so do not write this off
based on the first issue i don't know
why you would i don't know why you would
read one issue of a comic and then be
like this sucks the whole thing is going
to be dumb and then throw it away i
don't really know why why you would take
that stance but nonetheless you
basically switch over to what is in
effect the consciousness of eddie brock
as he just kind of is seemingly flown
through time and then eventually wakes
up in this place right almost a sort of
garden almost a kind of a lush and green
planet that has these very strange
exotic colors and flora and fauna and so
this voice seemingly comes out of
nowhere and it says welcome don't try to
talk you've just reconstituted yourself
from the available matter you'll need a
minute to gain your bearings this is
your first step on a long long road and
he says but i'll be with you every step
of the way and he says my name is
meridius and here at the furthest end of
all that is i welcome you to my garden
what it looks like here is eddie brock's
in the far shore that's what it looks
like and if it is that's cool i love the
far shore the far shore is like the
greatest concept that marvel never did
anything with okay so here's something
to understand when it comes to i guess
how the far shore works right so you
guys know in marvel comics you have like
the multiverse right like seemingly an
endless number of universes so imagine
this is all in like a giant circle kind
of how the way dc does their multiverse
and then you might have a layer right
the layer around that might be something
like the negative zone and then beyond
that would be like the realm of death
and then beyond that is the far shore
now beyond that is like the land of
couldn't be shouldn't be anything that
could possibly happen that hasn't
happened yet that's that realm and then
beyond the land of couldn't be shouldn't
be that's when you get into the
beyonders but the far shore is basically
the realm of like the one above all
that's really what it is right like the
place beyond everything so it's where
like all those meetings that you see in
mobile comics where like the living
tribunal is meeting with the cosmic
entities and they're in like a giant
empty space that's the far shore right
it's something that was recently
introduced and expanded on in marvel but
that's basically the far short that in
effect eddie brock is just past all of
creation he's moved far beyond any of
that stuff now what this means for his
character i have no clue but i will say
this man i am excited to find out with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace